the Joe Rogan experience Tober 2008 to
June 2009 that's when I had an open mic
at the store and I just remember Michael
Jackson just died and I just remember
saying this energy was crazy that night
and there was an open mic there was like
16 comics in the main room and I was
like 14 and I was like no and then they
were like Justin's going third so we
didn't start doing the podcast of the
Ice House until 2009 yeah it was right
after I got passed no I don't think we
started it's a nice house until 2011 now
that I'm thinking about I think we
mostly did it at my house yeah first
year right - it was 2000 yeah 2011 that
makes that that's probably when I met
you so you but you were already rolling
by then well no I have no idea on stage
you were doing well I was doing well but
I didn't know who I was hmm I knew how
to make people laugh but I didn't know
like what I didn't know the process and
so mitzi was the one who like passed me
and the last guy she passed at the store
Wow and so I just remember being like oh
did she say to you she didn't say
anything she just pointed she looked at
Tommy and said make him a regular and he
was like like development spots and
she's like no he's ready and then I
remember being taken away and they were
like you've just been passed by Mitzi's
short like it was like a weird like Ren
Faire wizard thing what has happened to
you never happens and then I just
remember being like oh [ __ ] like I did
my research about the place and I just
remember being like hot damn and I'm
looking at her right now yeah and just
that feeling of like I've got to make
this happen I've got to make sure cuz
she'd never I don't even know when the
last time she came to the store was but
you know everyone she was ill yeah and I
just wanted to be like god I hope this
wasn't like just her having dementia and
being like oh she's insane she picked
that guy dude when she passed me I
didn't sleep that night really no I was
lying in bed I remember thinking I can't
believe like I'm a paid regular at the
store I was already on TV yeah you know
a TV show yeah that didn't mean [ __ ] to
me yeah what meant something to me was
like I was a
I was a real comic now it's a stamp of
approval a guy had already been paid you
know I'm starting to cry Oh Joe get in
touch with the emotions it's normal I um
I'd already been doing stand-up like for
money you know I've done a lot of
headlining gigs I you know I travel I
did some road gigs and I did a lot of
stuff around New York before I came to
LA you know and then I was out here in
94 and she made me first sure maybe a
non-paid regular and I would go I'd go
on last every night and I was here every
next I didn't have any friends I was
staying at the Oakwood Garden Apartments
was pre furnished apartments and I was
on this television show that was
terrible
and I was just going to the store every
night I would work all day during the
thing I didn't have any friends and then
I would go to the comedy store and
that's that's where I feel like tried to
find a home a family yeah yeah so I got
these late-night sets it was like you
know it was always like five people in
the audience takes people in the
audience and then one night she passed
me she passed me I've told the story
before but there was a guy named the
Todd and the Todd had he's eventually he
developed like some pretty severe brain
issue like and he went insane and it was
really sad because back then I had seen
him before I ever came out here on MTV
on the half hour comedy hour uh-huh and
he sat down next to Mitzi while I was
onstage and laughed his ass off just ha
just the alarm debater in the Oh are in
the or and then I came out of stage and
she just goes okay you're past that was
it that was it that was my second
audition for the first one she made me a
non-paid regular and I did that for
months and then I became a paid regular
but did Todd pulled me aside and he said
he goes i sat there and he was you were
really funny he was what i sat there and
i laugh really [ __ ] hard and I told
Mitzi you're really funny and he goes
and you're gonna do that for other
people someday yeah it's a cool feeling
it's a cool feeling to actually had the
moment of seeing her I think it was at
the the it was a reunion of what was the
40th reunion
something couple years ago and they had
me on like the class of 2000 was like
Natasha
mmm some other people were on the line
up maybe even Duncan I don't know and
she was sitting in the back they brought
her in in a in her wheelchair and I was
like I have to say hi to her you know
I'd never I didn't get to say hi to her
I didn't get to meet her the last time
she just pointed and took off and I kind
of like I went up to her and I've looked
in her eyes and I shook her hand and I
said hi I'm Justin it's it's a honor to
meet you and I just want to say thank
you because you changed my life
and she just stared at me and I was like
she doesn't even know and then all of a
sudden she just squeezed my hand and
that was it oh that's all I needed so
that that to me was like oh she's there
she gets it yeah you know she'd had
those moments that she'd be in and out
mm-hmm
but I mean that's everything that I've
done that's led up to where I'm at now
has been for her too because I haven't
had other than my other than my mom and
my friends back home I've never had
somebody really believe in me like that
you know what I mean right it's very
special it's very special and just yeah
to be a part of a family her you know
and that's what it was I mean and that's
what helped me getting out of that like
I'm not good enough and I'm moving home
it's like oh wow I actually have a home
now and every time I go there now I just
feel so welcome and you know it's it's
it's nice it's a fraternity it's a
sorority it's a university you name yeah
it really is
[Applause]